Smart robots are no longer the stuff of science fiction.
But intelligence is more
than besting humans at board games.
It's basic physical skills, too —
like turning door knob or opening a bag.
Babies take  sensory information
from the world around them to figure out
how to use their bodies and interact.
Robots aren't quite as sophisticated.
In the past, they've failed pretty epically
at controlling their bodies.
But new improvements could go a long way
to help machines sense the physical world and
learn new skills based on what they see, feel or hear.
Some senses are more easily mastered than others.
If you have an iPhone you might interact with Siri,
an acoustically astute artificial intelligence
that picks up on your speech patterns
to better respond to questions.
"Hi, Siri, are you alive?"
"In the cloud, no one questions your existential status."
Other senses are trickier.
Take touch.
Humans are bombarded with tactile information
through skin —
temperature, pressure, texture...
Researchers at the University of Colorado
took a similar approach with a robot named Baxter.
They gave it smart skin
that translates a flood of vibration data
into simple messages.
Baxter's sensors can differentiate between
15 different textures.
Touch sensors also need to be tough.
SAIL-R, a bot developed by a team at Stanford
wears durable sensors on twirling legs.
Soon it may be able to tell hard ground
from grass or sand —
and adjust the way it scrambles forward.
But there's a difference between sensing
the world around you
and actually doing something with that information.
Researchers at UCLA gave their robot
squishy sensitive finger pads
and a plastic bag full of cheerios.
The robot actually figured out how to close the bag —
on its own.
Touch is a handy skill,
but staying upright is a pretty important one.
Your inner ear, eyes and feet
all  give you a sense of balance.
Some robots, like Atlas, are equipped with
body and leg sensors that do the same thing.
Atlas might take a tumble now and then,
but a new upgrade enables the bot to get right back up.
So that's hearing, touch, balance...
What about sight?
Lasers can tell a robot how far it is
from an object or obstacle
Google's driverless car also uses
lasers, radar, cameras and software
to recognize the shape of a pedestrian
or the outstretched arm of a cyclist.
Other robots tackle even more complex visual challenges.
Star is a surgical robot with senses
that go beyond human abilities
It has 3-D and near infrared cameras —
like wearing night-vision goggles.
Star can see glowing dots marked by humans on tissue,
calculate a stitch plan and sew up a live animal —
and maybe one day a human patient.
Star's makers hope to add more superhuman senses,
like measuring blood.
Things that seem like baby steps for humans
are giant leaps for robotkind,
especially robots designed to work in the real world.
Stickybot, for example, is a gecko-inspired robot
that uses special toe pads to scale walls.
MicroTugs are teeny tiny robots that can haul
materials hundreds of times their body weight.
Smart physical sensors can make these bots
more aware of their environment
and allow them to focus on more complex tasks.
One day, such sensitive robots might not work for us
or against us...
but alongside us.